herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
leute in dem wir heute eine serie weiter
für die schon fast kultstatus und zwar
die serien der unter anderem entstanden
ist youtube nach machen häufiger mit der
flügel von folge nach macht das bereits
im ersten jahr zu einem video im
heutigen video setze ich mir von der
politik nach den kopf packen dann
schnell drehen davon aufbauen und dann
lässt freunde ich habe mein freund sein
will die sommeraktion wendel
[Applaus]
das sehen diese 1000 grad heiß wurde mal
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
machen
von der bekommt im neuen viele leute
heute reagiert wie auch schnelle havel
[Musik]
mit neustetten auf der suche nach wasser
verwenden heuer nichts mit ihrem video
oberkörper frei
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was geht da ich mir und ich begrüße dass
ich sogar ein video ich bin heute mit
meinem vater habe
doch wieso bleibt dabei ein ihren die
kommentarschreiber gewonnen hat machte
verdient ja nicht hier bekommt ihr
können